[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pascal pavageau le secrétaire général de
force ouvrière est l'invité de l'épreuve
de vérité bon soir là et merci beaucoup
à bien ce avec nous d'avoir accepté
notre invitation donc au nom de public
sénat des échos de radio classique et de
l' afp deux médias représentés ce soir
ici sur le plateau par charlotte
gauthier et deborah claude bonsoir
mesdames et merci d'être là avec nous
également pascal pavageau vous allez
répondre au cours de cette émission à
trois grandes questions 1 et faut fêter
le choix de la radicalité avec le
soutien à la poursuite de la grève des
cheminots ou encore avec eux cette
journée d'action avec la cgt
ce sera à vendredi 2 le mot réforme est
il pour vous forcément synonyme de
sotchi rien enfin troisième question
derrière la défense des services publics
et des fonctionnaires l'enjeu numéro un
pour vous d'ailleurs comme pour les
autres syndicats n'est-il pas plutôt les
élections professionnelles qui vont se
dérouler à la fin de l'année et qui
permettront justement de connaître le
poids respectif des différentes
centrales du pays tout de suite la
première question de l'épreuve de vérité
avec charlotte gauthier
[Musique]
bonsoir monsieur pavageau bonsoir j'ai
un peu envie de vous demander fin juin
vous êtes toujours vers les cheminots
ils sont ultra minoritaires maintenant
en tout cas dans le pays dans l'opinion
même les grévistes sont plus très
nombreux
vous associez à la cgt pour une journée
d'action vendredi est-ce que vous avez
pas finalement fait le choix de la
radicalité chez fo non il n'y a pas de
choix de la radicalité le chouette force
ouvrière il est toujours le même c'est à
dire d'essayer d'être constructif là où
on le peut d'essayer de négocier là où
on le peut de porter nos idées de porter
la défense que nous avons pour les
travailleurs de ce pays soient dans une
entreprise dans une branche ou sur le
plan interprofessionnel au niveau de la
confédération ce qu'est radical c'est la
politique qui est menée en face c'est le
rouleau compresseur quéméner en face
mais c'est aussi la méthode de refusé
justement de dialoguer de concerter
pourquoi les cheminots sont plus de
choix du coup on poursuit la grève
éternellement le texte général d'une
grande confédération d'une vieille
confédération je soutiens par définition
et si le moins que je puisse faire eu
égard au mandat que j'ai reçu de la part
de l'ensemble des syndicats force
ouvrière ma l'ensemble des camarades fo
l'ensemble des salariés qui se sont eux
en luttant combat de surcroît en
l'occurrence pour défendre par exemple
les cheminots leur cadre collectif nommé
lyonnais dans le genre détruire sur le
mélange des ans notamment en jouant bien
à force ouvrière ce sont les syndicats
qui décident en l'occurrence ya des
assemblées générales ma fédération la
fédération fo des cheminots elle prend
ses positions et quelles que soient les
positions qu'elle prendra nous les
soutiendrons nous les épauleront nous
les accompagnerons comme nous le
pourrons sur le plan confédéral c'est
tout à fait cohérent c'est le mandat
d'abord premièrement que je reçois de
jeu reçoit de la part de mes camarades
et puis en plus c'est le rôle d'une
confédération
ben que d'aider et de soutenir celles et
ceux qui sont encore mais nous sommes
mais bien sûr alors si vous me laissez
deux minutes sur les cheminots lorsque
nous demandons à l'époque en avril 2018
c'est à dire le 28 avril 2018 pour être
précis nous demandons au gouvernement un
moratoire nous disons il nous faudrait
un mois un mois pourquoi pour négocier
pour négocier la question du statut 227
mille personnes qui sont aujourd'hui
dans
a la sncf et donc qui risque de passer
demain dans des entreprises privées du
fait de l'ouverture à la concurrence
donc garantie c'est par la négociation
le cadre collectif le cadre ses astuces
terre de 500 mètres 7000 personnes
on nous répond non nous refusons on
casse dogmatiquement par la loi alors
que rien ne l'y oblige le cadre
collectif et on renvoie à une
hypothétique négociations et nous disons
à l'époque au premier ministre que se
passera-t-il si le patronat de la
branche de la filière refuse de négocier
après que vous ayez casser le statut
on nous dit bao vous pensez que ça peut
rendre arriver jusque là eh bien c'est
ce qui s'est passé vendredi dernier on
avait au ministère des transports un
patronat qui dit nous ne sommes pas là
pour négocier la nouvelle convention
collective
nous sommes là pour appliquer
strictement la loi à savoir la casse du
statut
excusez moi mais aujourd'hui les 127 me
cheminots ils sont à poil ils n'ont plus
de statut on leur a cassé et on leur
refuse la négociation d'avoir un cadre
collectif de demain là qu'est ce qu'il
leur reste à part le rapport de force et
notamment de poursuivre la mobilisation
pour essayer de savoir entendre
simplement pour pouvoir négocier l'aide
qu'il leur reste la grève je le rappelle
effectivement qu'ils sont moins de 10%
aujourd'hui les cheminots avis tant ils
sont plus importants que les conducteurs
bien sûr on va écouter philippe martinez
va qui dit la même chose que vous
évidemment sur la poursuite de la grève
même cet été donc le leader de la cgt
qui était sur public sénat
il reste aussi un moyen d'action quand
on n'est pas écouté le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'on n'est pas
écoutée elle narre le gouvernement non
un moyen d'action mais on a l'impression
que c'est quand même une impasse
aujourd'hui moins de 10%
vous prenez un sabre et vous fait
hara-kiri les 127 milles personnes et
vous mobiliser pas on vient
idéologiquement de casser le cadre
collectif de votre emploi et derrière ça
on vous dit vous avez un employeur qui
refuse à reprendre des employeurs qui
refuse de négocier la convention
collective ou plutôt qui va vous donner
quelques queue de cerise et on vous dit
vous prenez ça sans vous mobiliser sans
essayer de vous défendre
mais moi je trouve parfaitement cohérent
que dans les assemblées générales
l'immense majorité des cheminots décide
de poursuivre la mobilisation moins de
10 % c'est pas parce qu'elles ne se
traduit pas en capacité d'être encore en
grève alors qu'ils le sont depuis
plusieurs semaines qu'il n'y a pas une
vraie rancoeur qu'il n'y a pas une vraie
colère qu'il n'y a pas une vraie
amertume et qu'est ce qu'on préfère une
grève ou des opérations qu'ils soient
des opérations on va dire violentes ou
déposent opération à un moment donné de
casse du matériel ou de je ne sais pas
nous at on dit et ben oui eh ben qui
poussent à cette situation la journée
mais bien sûr c'est de la radicalité la
radicalité du mouvement parce qu'on ne
reconnaît pas les organisations
syndicales est la plus fortement
on refuse simplement ce que nous
demandons depuis des semaines à savoir
négocier ou renégocier l'extension
l'évolution de ce conflit une logique de
radicalité de la prochaine fois ce soit
pas une semi ce qu'ils soient arrachés
voilà c'est à dire mais c'est à dire un
moment donné des mobilisations de
violence je constate qu'on est obligé de
se mettre dans un hôpital il faut quinze
jours de grève de la faim pour obtenir
30 postes mais on est où là
simplement parce que la rs et parce que
le gouvernement refuse de négocier des
gens des hommes et des femmes celles et
ceux qui nous sauve tous les jours dans
l'hôpital public qui demande pas une
augmentation de salaire là qui demande
pas leur statut qui demandent à pouvoir
réaliser correctement leur job avec 50
postes qui sont identifiés en moins on
ne leur donne pas et on pousse cette
personne à faire quinze jours de grève
de la faim qu'elle violence qu'elle
radicalité pour pouvoir avoir simplement
30 postes in fine est au bout du bout en
refusant la table de négociations
maîtrisant sa des 40 méprisant les à la
cfdt l'unsa disent avoir obtenu des
me c'est faux et alors qu'elle avance et
moi j'attends maintenant les éléments
concrets en matière d'avancées il y
avait un statut il n'y en a plus voté
idéologiquement de par la loi alors que
rien ne l'y obligeait où est la nouvelle
convention collective a dit oui mais on
ne le saura que quand la négociation que
la queue quand la négociation sur la
nouvelle convention collective aura
abouti qu nous nous avons fait une
demande concrète de laisser le temps un
mois un mois de négociations pour
étendre comme ça avait été fait lors de
l'ouverture à la concurrence sur
l'énergie avec le statut des industries
électriques et gazières qu'on est le
statut de la sncf etc on l'étendait à
l'ensemble des opérateurs pour maintenir
au minimum le cadre collectif ça régler
l'intégralité des problèmes sa revente
ou est-ce que sur cette crainte que vous
formulez d'une radicalisation de
mouvements violents vous êtes arrivé à
la tête de fo au mois d'avril est ce que
vous avez fait part à l'exécutif
directement emmanuel macron ou edouard
philippe de cette crainte qui est
formulée par ailleurs par d'autres
responsables sur deux aux deux que vous
écoutez en ce qui me concerne que ce
soit l'ensemble de l'exécutif mais aussi
à des représentants parlementaires ou
autre et via aussi les médias
je n'ai eu de cesse de dire attention à
mépriser à laisser de côté le dialogue
social la démocratie sociale les
contrepoids que représentent les
organisations syndicales et ce à tous
les niveaux dans l'entreprise jusqu'au
niveau interprofessionnel on s'expose à
un risque à un moment donné démocratique
qui soit le même discours que son berger
pour le coup mais il se croit
directement la question et je n'ai pas
de la république j'ai vu secrétaire
général de l'elysée je lui ai exposé
directement je lui ai exposé directement
premier ministre à madame pénicaud et à
d'autres représentants du gouvernement
je les exprimer publiquement dans les
médias y compris par écrit on s'expose à
un moment donné un risque démocratique
que lorsqu'on nous dit vous avez une
mobilisation genre celle du 22 mai dans
la fonction publique où aujourd'hui le
taux de grévistes à la sncf est
relativement faible
il ya plein il ya plein de caractère
qu'il explique mme et notamment le fait
que vous entendez de la part de
militants syndicaux et pas que de force
ouvrière le fait de dire la grève la
mobilisation traditionnelle ne sert plus
à rien la prochaine fois on fera
autre chose qui est du autre chose et
surtout de qui sera derrière le autre
jour vous attend sur un plan des mois
nous nous sommes un organisme nous
sommes des organisations démocratiques
nous sommes les organisations
responsables nous sommes des
organisations passif rigueur de fait
nous sommes des organisations
républicaines parce que nous sommes un
contrepoids nous sommes un contrepoids
longueur de proue mais bien évidemment
mais dans cette logique de contrepoids
il y a aussi cette logique un moment
donné d'essayer
2 comment dirais-je organiser la
capacité de réaction et de mobilisation
dans le respect des valeurs
républicaines et démocrates mais quand
vous lisez par exemple laurent laurent
brun qu'est le responsable de la cgt
cheminots vanter son léninisme il a
expliqué dans une revue que son objectif
était révolutionnaire et qui était il
était à la tête d'une organisation
révolutionnaire
là on est plus que le garde-fou oui mais
je suis pas d'ailleurs de ça lui
appartient
oui mais je soutiens avant le chan qui
ne vaut pas votre credo non ça c'est ma
copine qui refroidit c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire avec aude et ça lui
appartient et sa bande organisée ce
n'est pas une question de partenaires on
attend dé moi je parle jamais de
partenaires sociaux je parle d'
interlocuteur interlocuteurs sociaux
votre court de tennis on n'est pas entré
votre intervention de vue là avec qui
que ce soit donc moi là dessus il ya des
interlocuteurs sociaux qui sont
d'ailleurs patronaux comme syndicats la
cgt cheminots ou bien je m'initie j'ai
parfaitement entendu en ce qui nous
inscrit me concerne vous l'aurez
remarqué c'est force ouvrière et nous ne
sommes pas léniniste nous sommes un
syndicat rien qu'une organisation
syndicale
nous sommes libres nous sommes
indépendants ça explique notamment 1947
et de ce point de vue là je ne suis
encarté nulle part et mes camarades pour
l'immense majorité d'entre non mais pas
révolutionnaire et je ne suis pas
révolutionnaire sauf si la révolution
site dire par exemple qu'on passe le
smic à 1350 euros net et à 80% du
salaire médian dans ces cas là ce serait
une belle révolution sociale première
question de notre sondage opinionway qui
va vous plaire monsieur pavageau nous
avons demandé effectivement si
l'opposition des syndicats aux réformes
lancées par le gouvernement
été légitimement contestée par les
syndicats dont il faut aimer écouter
pour 56% des français
les syndicats sont dans leur rôle oui
enfin je crois surtout que les syndicats
sont dans leur rôle lorsqu'ils proposent
et nous à force ouvrière c'est ce que
nous essayons de faire le problème c'est
que nous proposons aujourd'hui dans le
vide
c'est à dire que on ne nous écoute pas
on ne nous entend pas d'ailleurs
regardez l'immense majorité de vos
confrères nous invite à chaque fois pour
dire vous vous faites attaquer vous fait
rentrer dedans donc vous résistez ce qui
ce qui est une réalité mais ça ne laisse
pas de place aux propositions que nous
pouvons avoir nous nous pouvons formuler
or nous sommes avant tout des gens qui
sont constructifs vous vous engagez pas
dans l'organisation syndicale pour user
vos chaussures
tous les samedis sur le pavé pour brûler
des palettes ou pour arracher des
chemises vous engagez des organisations
syndicales pour protéger pour défendre
pour proposer pour construire vos
collègues de travail
l'ensemble des travailleurs de votre
branche chez les ch'tis c'est ce qu'il
soit enfin dit je suis en train de vous
dire on mentionne pas la violence nous
on en a entre brûler des palettes
chômage élevé mieux le mieux c'est
simplement de pouvoir se mettre autour
de la table et d'obtenir par la
concertation et la négociation du
progrès social pour tous c'est ça le
mieux
mais pour pouvoir aller à la table de
négociation faut qu'on nous y invite au
look à monsieur paré jose avait prévu
d'user encore un peu vos semelles sur le
pavé vendredi avec la cgt pour cette je
le dis par an 28 excusez moi pour cette
journée d'action avec la cgt
mais finalement pourquoi vous n'allez
pas proposer là je dis vous où on est là
pour que nous nous sommes là pour
prendre date dans une logique qui
s'inscrit à plus long terme et
certainement avec plus d'organisations
syndicales et de jeunesse que celle qui
appelle le 28 sur un mouvement
interprofessionnel au mois de septembre
mois d'octobre nous verrons à la rentrée
fin août début septembre ce que nous
sommes en capacité de faire la dernière
mobilisation interprofessionnelle du 19
avril a pas été très réussie mais c'est
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure là
en l'occurrence sur le 28 juin
on n'est pas là pour faire un chiffre on
est là simplement pour prendre date
voilà et s'est inscrit aux mélodies
paris moi je serai pas à paris je serai
dans le doubs avec mes camarades dans le
doubs mais le jeu ne verra pas à côté de
monsieur martinez
non mais c'était prévu de longue date et
il n'y a pas de problème particulier
avec qui que ce soit j'ai vu l'ensemble
de mes homologues secrétaires généraux
nous nous verrons d'ailleurs nous nous
voyons régulièrement ce soit à 5 ou a+
donc de ce point de vue là il n'y a
absolument pas de même des choses quand
même une peut-être une porte de sortie
je ne sais pas où vous toutes lettres
que vous lancez une boule cgt qui a fait
un pas de deux avec la france 1 cerise
mais ça n'a pas très bien marché je
crois que la ccp a besoin de la base de
blanc et de la part de force ouvrière ou
de quoi que ce soit et je sais très mal
dans ces je pense que philippe martinez
m'a pas l'air d'un extraordinairement
danseurs donc on dansera pas le pas de
deux mille pattes 3 ni et c'est par
contre on est sur la préparation d'un
mouvement plus large
interprofessionnelle dans l'unité
d'action la plus large avec le maximum
d'organisations syndicales et de
jeunesse en septembre ou en octobre on
se reverra fin août
dans ce cadre là parce que les attaques
de l'ensemble des mouvements qui
existent aujourd'hui on a beaucoup parlé
là des cheminots mais il y en a dans le
secteur public d'entendre parler de ce
point de vue là ils ont deux points
communs le premier c'est le refus de la
répartition de la richesse produite
c'est à dire la question du coût de la
modération des salaires et de la baisse
du pouvoir d'achat
il n'y a pas que les retraités qui sont
concernés par ça c'est un problème de
refus de la répartition de la richesse
produite par justement les salariés le
deuxième point c'est la logique de des
protections la casse des cadres
collectifs la cadre des conventions
collectives la casse des statuts bref
l'individualisation de notre société
ces deux sujets qui sont majeurs et
transversaux de notre point de vue
doivent pouvoir permettre un moment
donné de faire une unité d'action un peu
plus large y compris autour de réformes
qui individualise un droit aussi
fondamental que celui que la retraite
non mais ça nous verrons bacs à la
rentrée de septembre mais pas uniquement
à deux organisations syndicales à toutes
et tous et après chacun fera devant la
décision jeudi de mener dans les rues
donc vous contestez le terme de
radicalité qui pourrait enfin la
localité du côté du gouvernement le
projet de loi pacte alors d'en parler
mais vous vous présentez comme un aussi
comme un syndicat réformiste
oui oui alors il relève deux il n'y a
pas de mutations génétiques à force
ouvrière depuis 70 ans
on appelle ça nous le réformisme
militants sa simple ça se résume en deux
mots lorsque c'est bon on le dit lorsque
c'est pas bon on le dit aussi
et alors on ne comptera que ça allait la
deuxième partie
de l'épreuve de vérité tout de suite
avec la question que va vous poser
maintenant deborah claude justement la
réforme on en parlait alors ce que la
réforme est ce que c'est forcément
synonyme de thatchérien pour vous bien
sûr que non et on aimerait bien
justement que la réforme elle soit du
progrès social
elle a été elle n'a été si on va pas
repartir trop trop loin mais finalement
de l'après-guerre à a à peu près le
milieu des années 80 la quasi totalité
de l'ensemble des réformes sociales
s'inscrivait dans une logique de progrès
social
c'est une logique de compromis
évidemment toutes les revendications
n'aboutissent et pas sur le plan
syndical
mais il y avait un vrai progrès social
il y avait l'instauration d'un salaire
minimum il y avait d'instauration de la
sécurité sociale il y avait des aides
sociales
il y avait une service public
républicain bref il y avait une prise
une construction collective y compris
par la négociation dans l'ensemble des
conventions collectives qui ont existé
par la négociation du progrès social qui
aboutit à ce que 93 % aujourd'hui des
travailleurs de ce pays soient couverts
par une convention collective ou par un
statut à partir des années 80 on
commence à avoir du fait de l'austérité
budgétaire du fait de du tout marché du
fait du poids de la finance dans les
politiques mondialisée une attaque
frontale justement sur ces droits
collectifs
donc on commence à avoir des
organisations syndicales qui n'ont plus
de grain à moudre et qui commence à être
sur la défensive
aujourd'hui c'est plus une question g
août c'est de protéger la meule parce
qu'ils sont en train de vouloir la casse
et y compris en refusant de négocier
qu'à citer là on parle beaucoup de la
refonte des aides sociales
on connaît absolument pas l' excellent
exemple de non réforme
l'efficace conforme thème pour vous ça
c'est faire une réforme
qu'est ce que ça veut dire très bien par
non d'efficacité nous on a toujours été
favorable et les normales palm que le
parlement évalue les aides publiques
quelles qu'elles soient
dans ces cas là on pourrait faire en
parallèle d'une évaluation des aides
sociales et des aides publiques pour les
plus pauvres et les plus démunis
l'évaluation de 140 milliards d'euros
annuels aux entreprises sans
contrepartie ils vont être contents
elles vont être rognés annoncé le
gouvernement les moins efficaces des
aides aux entreprises vont être
supprimés vous n'êtes que l'on va
conditionner si elles ne sont pas
efficaces oui mais surtout qu on les
conditionne nous n'a toujours été
favorables à l'intervention publique
on a été favorable interne dans son bus
dès lors qu'à l'aide de l'innovation
dès lors qu'elles aident line générer
dès lors qu'à l'aide l'industrie dès
lors qu'elle est de la création
évidemment et le maintien de l'emploi
donc le fait d'avoir une aide publique
qu'ils soient conditionnées alizés qui
sont ensuite contrôler qu'ils soient
suivis évalué puis contrôlé ne nous pour
accor relève c'est de l'argent public
il est quand même normal que ce soit
évalué que ce soit contrôlée mais
s'attaquer au problème en sous-entendant
qu'il y aurait un pognon de dingue pour
les 14% d'entre nous qui sont
aujourd'hui les plus pauvres donc qu'ils
sont à un niveau de seuil de pauvreté
alors qu'on sait que ces aides sociales
on le sait déjà instantanément elle
représente une logique de digues qui
évite que nous passions instantanément
de 14 % à 22 % de la population en
termes de niveau de pauvreté donc c'est
à la fois une digue
mais c'est aussi une main tendue c'est
aussi une corde puisque le président de
la république aime bien les premiers de
cordée
c'est aussi une main tendue à ses 14 %
d'entre nous alors maîtrise répondu on
va vous aider à mieux d'en sortir
l'enfant la question seriez rien de dire
ça de contester reprendre les scripts
lens qui était de cherien cette attaque
est idéologiquement et dogmatiquement au
cadre collectif
l'ensemble y compris les aides sociales
les statuts qui nous protège qui font
notre république et le prix l'égalité
républicaine maxi et thatchérien c'est
d'avoir une logique de méthodes qu'ils
soient je pense donc tu suis un con
certes pas je fais de rythme annuel même
temps et donc de ce point de vue là oui
sur la méthode comme en termes de
politique qui est menée
d'individualisation et de casey droite
des cadres collectifs
il y a quelque chose qui s'apparente à
ce qui a été connu malheureusement en
grande bretagne sous l'ère de madame
thatcher sauf que madame thatcher né et
ai été avec une logique qui était avant
tout une logique ultralibérale
d'ouverture à la concurrence de casser
tout ce qui était dans de service public
ou de cadres publics là aujourd'hui on
va plus loin avec cette logique
d'individualisation c'est une vraie
vision société
c'est une vision c'est une vision de
société qui est de 10
chacun pour soi chacun se débrouille la
petite musique derrière le pognon de
dingue dès que pour les 14% de plus
pauvres c'est aussi sous-entendre que
ces 14 % serait un peu responsable de la
situation dans laquelle ils se
retrouvent entendu ma philosophie est de
dire je vous dis c'est bien les
spéciales mais ça me met à rin et
visionnaire mais pas de réduire la
pauvreté mais c'est faux l'exemple que
je donne tout de sortir de près de 14 %
de pauvres dans la série d'être réduit à
lézignan dans la cinquième puissance
économique du monde c'est inadmissible
c'est intolérable
donc je préférerais une réforme qui nous
disent on va avoir une vraie loi pour
lutter contre les inégalités avec un
objectif qu'ils soient que demain nos 14
% passe à 0
quand ça j'aimerais bien cette réforme
là et croyez bien qu'on l'accompagnerait
et qu'il ya plein de propositions que
nous avons des années qu'ils pourraient
se retrouver notamment sur le partage de
la richesse produite dans un tel projet
de loi pour lutter contre les inégalités
quand vous expliquer qu'à travers les
sondages les français 100 m
majoritairement d'accord avec le fait
que trop d'argent mais pas assez
d'efficacité de ces aides sociales c'est
bien qu'il ya quelque chose qui cloche
c'est bien quelque chose qu'il faut
revoir mais parce que aujourd'hui on
revient sur la question de l'évaluation
moi j'ai aucun problème sur l'évaluation
l'évaluation elle doit être menée et
notamment mais c'est par le gouvernement
d'après vous et non mais qu'est ce qu'un
gouvernement il ya du pognon de dingue
c'est quoi ça s'évalue à 5 et 10 ans
mais on s'en sortir par le travail en
sortir par l'émancipation
alors les deux tiers les deux tiers des
adultes qui sont dans les 14 % ont soit
un emploi soit on recherche un
activement un sdf sur quatre en france à
une activité 12% des sdf en france ont
un emploi
vous croyez que ces femmes ces hommes
ces enfants qui sont dans cette
situation là n'essaye pas de s'en sortir
et d'essayer de trouver un boulot pour
se sauver eux-mêmes et surtout leurs
familles et leurs proches
mais franchement laissé penser que ce
serait des gens qui profiterait du
système
c'est abject comme discours c'est
inadmissible et ce n'est pas digne
effectivement des valeurs républicaines
donc 14 % c'est beaucoup trop
non qu'on nous explique que peut-être il
y aller dispositif qui devrait être
renforcée pour permettre à ce que demain
c'est 14% soit encore réduit mais
engageant cette discussion là sous le
prix
de l'efficacité des aides et pas que mon
temps selon lequel soi-disant il y
aurait un pognon d'un qui serait de 14,8
et d'emmanuel magon bas j'en sais rien
moi je suis pas psy fin fond ce temps là
dessus est ce que je trouve simple
vision il ya une vision qui essayent de
l'individualisation le problème c'est
qu'une vision sans valeur sans les
valeurs d'égalité sans les valeurs de
fraternité c'est extraordinairement
dangereux
on va parler du chômage mais d'abord je
vais vous présenter le résultat de la
deuxième question de notre sondage
opinionway pour l'épreuve de vérité
justement sur notre modèle social plaît
bien pour 63% des français
la politique du gouvernement ben le
remette en cause
je ne serais pas surpris non je suis pas
sur votre compte si je suis surpris que
ce soit 63% parce que la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est 'qui le modèle social
français c'est la république c'est
l'égalité républicaine
et ce sont des droits collectifs nous
adossons nos droits qui s'utilise
évidemment de façon individuelle sur la
base de ce statut au sens général le
statut stade utah larié par exemple de
droits collectifs et le fait de casser
ou de ne plus reconnaître ni les
contrepoids qui sont du collectif ni les
cadres collectifs que nous avons
construit tous ensemble depuis plus de
100 ans
et bien c'est antinomique de notre
modèle aura parlé de l'objectif du
gouvernement en matière d'emploi et de
chômage emploi chômage c'est une réforme
qui est en cours de discussion qui
arrive au sénat la semaine prochaine en
commission donc que l'assurance-chômage
la formation professionnelle que pour
ses vous de ces réformes est ce qu'elles
vont permettre de créer des emplois
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que tu dis est
faux sur ces textes je crois qu'aucun
franchement je ne sais pas qu'est la
réforme un jour en france à créer des
emplois ce qui crée l'emploi
c'est évidemment d'une manière générale
le contexte macro économique c'est
l'activité s'est un peu le taux tourne à
l'environnement où les clichés les
salaires ça franchement ça je pense que
c'est très relatif en terme par exemple
renault le merdy avec sa nouvelle loi
pacte qu'elle va créer des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois ça vous fait marrer
ouais c'est une bonne blague c'est elle
et elle est drôle voilà
non mais c'est bien c'est pour avoir de
l'humour aussi quand on est ministre en
l'occurrence mais correctement l'afghane
rappelle un président du medef qui va
bientôt partir cave et un pin's avec un
million dans ces quatre pays dit qu'on
n'en est pas loin fait que je vois plus
en pin par contre que je voudrais pas
c'est que son successeur dans maintenant
une semaine et un pin's 36 millions de
précaires oui et pierre gattaz puisque
l'on parle de lui dit dans une interview
au figaro ce matin vous l'avez lu que
avec lui à la tête du medef nous avons
gagné le combat des idées 1 eelv a fait
reculer les rigidités sociale
il a fait reculer la pression fiscale
sur les entreprises ils sont félicite ce
que vous lui reconnaissez cette victoire
est ce que vous avez votre défaite
d'abord premièrement on n'est pas dans
une logique de match vous savez quand on
quand on se bat pour avoir du progrès
social pour celles et ceux qui
aujourd'hui de produit de la richesse en
france et souffrent au quotidien de la
part de leur travail
on s'inscrit pas dans une logique de
bras de fer ça c'est vraiment d'un mail
interne à remporter la victoire des
idées mais aujourd'hui objectivement et
depuis un certain temps et
particulièrement depuis un an mais même
sur les gouvernements précédents
la logique ultralibérale la logique de
dérégulation la logique dite de
compétitivité haute flexibilité est
effectivement malheureusement une idée
majeure qui est menée par l'ensemble des
gouvernements depuis des années et donc
de ce point de vue là le patronat peut
constater avec satisfaction que ce qu'il
demande lui est consentie par le
gouvernement ce qui était
extraordinairement dangereux aujourd'hui
sur l'aspect négociations
interprofessionnelles parce qu'il
faudrait pas que le nouveau président du
medef nous explique la semaine prochaine
qui n'a plus besoin de négocier avec les
organisations syndicales sur le plan
national
parce que quand ils demandent ça le
gouvernement lui donne déjà cette façon
automatique et donc que le patronat
refuse d'avoir une logique de
négociation et de compromis avec les
organisations syndicales pour faire
avancer notre démocratie sociale et
qu'on casse définitivement fait déjà
passé par le gouvernement à huawei à bas
le président du medef quel qu'il soit
demain matin peut dire au président de
la république merci patron parce qu'en
l'occurrence sur le plan politique il a
mais quand il demande sa il à jet de
deux fois plus avant même d'avoir
commencé à demander quelque chose donc
de ce point de vue là oui il a de quoi
d'être il a de quoi être satisfait oui
donc après sur la question de la
création d'emplois moi je encore une
fois ce n'est pas une réforme
d'un gouvernement de fermer tous les
coups de sang est ce qu'on a en tant qu
est ce qu est ce qu un jour dans notre
vie on a entendu un gouvernement un chef
de l'état nous expliquer un plan
économique il faisait une réforme pour
détruire de l'emploi je ne sais pas mais
franchement je me croyais je n'y crois
pas je n'ai je n'y crois absolument pas
parce que vous croyez
cette logique de flexibilité on relance
aux dents lac dans notre pays la
croissance elle est liée à peu près à
70% à la consommation donc auront
relance avant tout le moteur de la
croissance qui aide à la création
d'emplois et au minimum à son maintien
notamment par l'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat et par l'augmentation des
salaires
ça c'est ça c'est une vraie réalité
économique elle est invariable depuis
une centaine d'années
vous croyez en la formation
professionnelle bien sûr il ya trois
cent mille emplois qui ne sont non
pourvus dans notre pays parce qu'on
manque de compétences le gouvernement
veut réformer la formation
professionnelle et on se dit pas
peut-être qu'il est temps de sortir la
formation professionnelle du paritarisme
non c'est alors c'est sûr qu'un ministre
demain quels qu'ils soient je ne sais
pas quels seront les gouvernements que
nous aurons demain sera bien plus
compétents que les interlocuteurs
sociaux qui travaillent avec les pieds
dans l'entreprise auprès des salariés
pour savoir quels sont les besoins d'une
branche professionnelle du canton
bilingue mais non pourvus par manque de
manque de compétences oui mais c'est pas
énorme
rattaché à l'échelle du route c'est trop
mais c'est pas nous sommes donc dans des
entreprises dans ces trois cent mille
emplois il faut regarder les raisons
objectives qui font qu'on a peu de
candidats pour s'inscrire dans ces
filières
elles sont parfois liés à la pénibilité
du métier elles sont parfois liés à la
situation géographique de ces emplois
par exemple en zone rurale ou très
éloignées dans dans des incidents dans
des industries très très éloignées du
centre du du centre ville du centre
urbain et elles sont liées aux
rémunérations elles sont liées aussi aux
grilles de salaires donc tous ces
éléments là ce sont aux interlocuteurs
sociaux mais aussi au patronat de
pouvoir y répondre et aujourd'hui
franchement nous n'avons pas à rougir
l'ensemble des interlocuteurs sociaux du
bilan que nous avons sur la formation
professionnelle et ce depuis des
décennies alors lutter contre le recours
il faut contrats courts cdd par
certaines entreprises la ministre du
travail mme muriel pénicaud réaffirmé ce
matin
berry qu'elle était pour on l'écouté
vous réagissez un nombre important des
demandeurs d'emploi qui sont condamnés à
vie à la précarité si on n'agit pas
parce que ils sont ils à trouver que des
cdd intérim alors certaines aides via
l'allocation chômage
ce qu'on appelle la paire mi temps ce
faire des allers et retours entre
l'employeur et l'assurance chômage
mais quand on sait que 85% de 16 ans
placés chez le même employeur qui une
fois 10 x 20 x 30 x à rembaucher pour
une journée quelques jours la même
personne on se dit qu'il ya peut-être un
besoin permanent et qu'on peut faire
mieux
alors alors faire mieux ça veut dire
évidemment et faire payer les
entreprises la question du bonus malus
wii qui a voté aujourd'hui sur la table
d'accord mais on est à l'origine de la
proposition et ce depuis des années donc
sur le principe qu'un moment donné nous
ayons une décision qui soit une décision
réglementaire ou législative sur le
sujet
ne peut que nous aller même si nous
aurions préféré que le patronat
l'acceptent il y a quelques années et
que nous puissions nous mettre en place
par la négociation interpro ça n'a pas
été possible pour des refus idéologique
du combat des idées
cher monsieur chère à monsieur gattaz
donc en l'occurrence si le gouvernement
décide de le mettre en place il
l'annonçait pour la fin de l'année
nous y sommes favorables et nous avons
fait des propositions concrètes de
modalités techniques sérieux ces bonus
malus
ce que je veux simplement dire c'est que
nous souhaitons que le gouvernement
reste sur une traduction par la loi et
pas uniquement par un décret de manière
à ce que le principe soit bien actée
dans un texte législatif alors ça ça va
dans le bon sens donc pour vous je vais
pas dire qu'on va pas dans le bon alors
là bien compris que le gouvernement va
le mettre en place parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'il ya des du flottement
je vais essayer de pas faire de procès
d'intention
donc je vous dis madame la ministre
vient de rappeler que à la fin elle elle
l'avait déjà dit elle a déjà dit
plusieurs fois que quand les gens disent
plusieurs fois louison mais pose écouter
elle avait dit au mois de mars au nom du
gouvernement à la fin de l'année si on
n'est pas en capacité de le mettre dans
la loi à ce stade j'aurais préféré qu'il
soit dans la loi à ce stade et nous
avons poussé dans ce dans ce sens donc
nous verrons à la fin de l'année pierre
dury thorium nous lui ferons des
propositions concrètes comme nous
l'avons déjà fait à ses prédécesseurs
sur la traduction de ce bonus mais il
faut comprendre quand même un autre
sujet celui des retraites qui est très
important pour l'instant la concertation
n'a pas commencé vous semblez déjà être
fâché par les éléments qui semblent
poindre dans la loi pacte sur cette
réforme des retraites
ce que nous avons dit au gouvernement
c'est que et au premier ministre
notamment c'est qu'il fallait la loyauté
de la concertation qui est menée
aujourd'hui par le commissaire à la
réforme des retraites
nommé par le gouvernement sur donne un
monsieur jean paul delevoye donc de ce
point de vue là nous n'avons pas
apprécié et nous l'avons dit en premier
ministre que
à monsieur delevoye pas monsieur le
maire puis on l'a pas vu puisqu'il n'a
pas consulté qu'il y ait des éléments
notamment sur l'épargne-retraite certes
c'est des petits éléments mais donc qui
concerne avait abandonné la question des
retraites qui n'ont pas été débattu ni
d'un côté dans la grande réforme dans la
grande consultation sur les retraites ni
sur le projet de loi pack donc attention
à ce que le gouvernement il aime pas les
grèves perlées nous on n'aime pas les
réformes parler donc on voudrait pas se
retrouver avec plein de petits éléments
sur la retraite qui soit crantée dans
des projets de loi sous la forme de
cabaye et législatives et qui souhaitent
se retourner en décembre 2010 18 avec
plein d'éléments sur la retraite qui
auront été décidés sur la question
globale des retraites
il est temps que le gouvernement sorte
du bois nous avons discuté des principes
nous avons discuté des principes nous ne
sommes pas d'accord sur cette logique de
casse de l'ensemble des régimes de
fusion des régies bhl est d'une logique
vu les valeurs d'une individualisation
de l'ensemble de la réforme par une
logique dite de refaire de de réforme
par point mais il faut maintenant que le
gouvernement mois de septembre sortent
du bois et nous donne le point
d'atterrissage c'est quoi concrètement
une réforme de retraite par points
médine
jean paul delevoye ou médine emmanuel
macron caisse les le système exact ne
serait ce que pour faire des simulations
ne serait ce que pour voir aujourd'hui
nathan oui on va attendre mais excusez
moi mais si c'est nous parler des grands
principes et faire un peu du blabla
générale en disant mais oui la main sur
le coeur on gardera les pensions de
réversion mais bien sûr on regardera les
paras de solidarité et ce pendant six
mois jusqu'à la fin de l'année et que
lorsque le projet de loi sort avec sa
réalité concrète en termes de mesures de
traduction des grands principes et qu'on
s'aperçoit que tous les grands principes
ils sont balayés au niveau de la réalité
ça ne peut pas aller donc la réforme
maintenant au mois de septembre et nous
l'avons dit au gouvernement c'est du
concret c'est quoi votre réforme par
exemple c'est là dessus qu'on me dise
qu'une version c'est pareil surtout la
caisse le maintien du statut t et donc
le maintien du sel est ce que est ce que
le code des pensions civiles et
militaires est intégralement maintenus
dans son cadre statutaire du fait d'une
logique de passage par points c'est une
question qui concerne des millions de
personnes alors que là dessus on attend
du concret encore une question à partir
de septembre
c'est le troisième parti une partie de
la droite se découvre antilibérale et
propose une hausse du smic de 20% vous
applaudissez vous vous êtes prêt à
troquer l'air contre macron moi je crois
que personne contre personne vous savez
nous on est une organisation syndicale
avec une organisation sénégal dont une
partie de notre revendication c'est de
passer de aujourd'hui le smic était à
peu près à 60% du salaire médian en
france à 80% du salaire médian
non je dis allez nico la droite ni rien
du tout en l'occurrence j'aimerais bien
que le gouvernement se saisisse aussi de
prolonger trois dans une logique de loi
contre les inégalités donc tant mieux si
des députés
quels que soient leur majorité pouces
pour une augmentation du salaire minimum
en france c'est ce que nous demandons là
aussi depuis des mois ça répond à un
enjeu économique comme je le disais tout
à l'heure mais la consommation à la
croissance donc à notre logique est
votre démonstration tout à leur
troisième partie des pôles vérité avec
donc charlotte qui vous pose la question
[Musique]
est ce que finalement derrière la
défense des services publics tout ce qui
vous tient à coeur vous avez le temps de
développer l'enjeu numéro un c'est pas
aussi l'objectif final les élections
professionnelles à la fin de l'année
2018 dans un contexte compliqué pour les
syndicats on a toujours été opposé dès
2008 dans le secteur privé puis ensuite
en 2010 dans le secteur public à cette
logique de représentativité par
l'élection ça n'a pas de sens et ça
n'est pas notre rôle c'est transformer
les organisations syndicales en une
logique de parti politique qui à un
moment donné veulent gagner quoi une
élection parce que derrière la
représentativité souvent et vous est-ce
c'est une réalité il y a des moyens il y
a les moyens syndicaux par exemple en
termes de décharges d'activité de
service et c'est comme ça donc une
passionnée non pas permettre compte et
de se comparer elles existent elles
existent elles nous sont imposés donc
nous ne sommes pas stupides on n'est pas
en train de dire on s'en fiche et on va
pas chercher naturellement à gagner une
élection dans une entreprise dans une
branche à elle d'une branche ou dans le
secteur public pour 5,4 millions de
personnes donc évidemment on se mobilise
dans ce sens là mais ça va large notre
défense du service public républicain
notre défense de ses 5,4 millions de
femmes et d'hommes qui sont ces s'est
engagé ordinaires qui sont un peu nos
nos héros du quotidien et qui sont notre
fierté à tous républicaine bah c'est
avant tout ça que nous défendons nous
les vendons le service public de
proximité nous défendons le service
public qui nous permet à toutes et tous
mais d'avoir un minimum d'égalité de
droits ou que nous soyons sur le
territoire national et quel que soit le
sujet qui nous adaptons gens quel que
soit ce que nous gagnons je veux
simplement dire que on dit souvent que
le principe même de la sécurité sociale
et c'est vrai c'est une logique très
noble en 45 était de dire je cotise
selon mes moyens mais je bénéficie selon
mes besoins
mais si vous regardez bien c'est le même
principe qui nous a permis de créer le
service public républicain parce que
qu'on soit imposable ou pas on a le
droit à tous les services plus aux mêmes
services publics que si on paye les sf
la vente exactement le même de re div et
ça c'est un héritage qui nous honorent
question des services publics on attend
un rapport qui me vient une arlésienne
maintenant cap 22
le vois pas sortir certains me disent
c'est au courant de l'été il n'arrive
pas ça va sortir par bribes
est ce que vous avez peur de 4,22 qu'est
ce qui va se passer sur nous on n'a pas
peur d'eux qu'à 22,6 et le cap de
désespérance parce que ça a l'air d'être
quand même celui là avec l'histoire des
30 milliards d'économies budgétaires
vous savez ça s'est appelée har gpp
avant-hier ça c'est appeler la map un
modernisation de l'action publique hier
ça s'appelle aujourd'hui cap de
désespérance est ce que vous allez
apporter vos rapports c'est en tout cas
ce qui m'inquiète plus c'est pas la
question que des 30 milliards
d'économies
ni même des 120 mille postes de
suppressions d'effectifs ça c'est
l'affichage politique traditionnelle que
l'on a et c'est la volonté des uns des
autres et dans la continuité des
gouvernements précédents quelle que soit
l'heure que ce qui m'inquiète le plus
c'est comme sur la sncf qu'on utilise en
l'occurrence soit une logique
ultralibérale soit là une rigueur
d'austérité budgétaire pour casser le
cadre collectif c'est-à-dire le média tu
ont recollé millions de femmes et
d'hommes
il ya des intérieurs je veux bien
évidemment qu'à un moment donné pour
n'importe quel gouvernement on a une
opération qui est contrainte de devoir
mener les politiques publiques qui
souhaitent en lien avec les recettes
publiques sont à la disposition
dans ces cas là on peut peut-être éviter
d'arrêter de tout accès ou dessous
demander à ceux qui touchent l isf ou au
niveau des entreprises pour pouvoir se
faire de la marge de manoeuvre ou
s'attaquer par exemple aux 80 milliards
perdus annuellement d'évasion fiscale
alors que 100 douaniers recruter
spécifiquement contre l'évasion fiscale
en remportant ramènerait au bas mot de
l'ordre de 20 à 25 millions chaque année
donc ce sont des choix politiques qui
sont faits mais trouver un peu plus de
recettes publiques et de marges
budgétaires c'est parfaitement possible
ce que nous condamnons là en
l'occurrence au delà de la question
dogmatique de baisser artificiellement
la dépense publique pour privatiser la
mission publique ce que nous condamnons
c'est une attaque frontale contre le
statut contre le statut avec à la fois
l'individualisation
aujourd'hui de la rémunération des
fonctionnaires qui est une nouvelle qui
est une tendance
on va dire accentuée depuis les derniers
le gouvernement s'il mérite
non non vous quand vous vous engagez
dans la fonction publique vous vous
engagez pas pour gagner au mérite vous
vous engagez pour défendre des valeurs
vous engager pour défendre des principes
et le premier des principes ça s'appelle
légalité et l'égalité de traitement
l'égalité de droits qui vont vers le
statut mon public donc c'est pas le
concours si ça vous pose un problème
vous créez votre start up vous allez
créer votre boîte ailleurs comme clé
cher à monsieur mâcon vous cherchez des
clients et vous cherchez pas un emploi
et certainement pas à la place à du der
donc un moment donné à schizophrénie ça
va deux minutes donc celles et ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui c'est 5,4 millions
personnes
ils se sont pas engagés pour gagner de
l'argent ils se sont engagés pour nous
défendre pour nous servir pour nous
soigner pour nous éduquer donc ça à ce
moment là pas tous mais le souhaite on
roule non seulement c'est pas une
question de les protéger c'est aussi
faire d'elle et 2 le fait qu'ils soient
des contrepoids des contrepoids
républicain dans notre démocratie parce
que les exécutifs passent mais la
république demeure et c'est eux qui en
sont les garants c'est eux qui en sont
la garantie sur la durée donc à ce
moment donné faut pas tout mélanger moi
ce qui m'inquiète aujourd'hui c'est une
attaque frontale à nouveau contre le
cadre collectif l'apa 227 mille
personnes mais de 5 4 millions de
personnes par l'individualisation de la
rémunération et par le recrutement sous
forme contractuelle
c'est à dire dérogatoire au statut de
manière à pouvoir placer des gens
partaient déjà dénoncé oui mais x le
contre williams il ya un million de
personnes qui sont contractuels
notamment dans la territoriale nous
l'avons condamné là le problème c'est la
dérogation affiché à tout recrutement
demain dans la fonction publique
territoriale dans l'hospitalière et dans
l'état d'ailleurs un amendement vient
d'être passé en catimini par le
gouvernement dans le projet de loi
justement égalité la de liberté pour
construire son parcours individuels
justement pour pouvoir recruter de façon
contractuelle l'ensemble des hauts
fonctionnaires soit disant pour donner
l'exemple
donc cette espèce de contractualisation
au plus haut niveau la fonction publique
pour ensuite généraliser la
contractualisation c'est la casse du
cadre collectif et du statut ça
s'inscrit dans cette logique et dans
cette vision de chacun pour soi
j'aimerais vous faire réagir un rapport
du sénat
auteur vincent capo-canellas ce qu'on va
écouter d'ailleurs sur les grèves record
dans en france du côté des contrôleurs
aériens 254 jours de grève 254 en 12 ans
alors que c'était 4 en allemagne 37 en
italie en écoute le sénateur en fait il
donne une explication on a cette
particularité de faire grève
non seulement pour des motifs qui sont
liées à la navigation aérienne mais
aussi parfois des grèves de solidarité
avec la fonction publique
vous avez des choses à dire sur ce
record de la france qui est responsable
de deux tiers des retards d'avion en
europe
les responsables de la grève moi je suis
désolé mais c'est pas ce qui la fonde
les responsables de la greffe et ceux
qui refusent négocier c'est ce qu'ils
refusent de concerter où c'est ceux qui
méprisent l'ensemble des salariés donc à
un moment donné faut sport qui font des
référendum à l'emporte-pièce alors que
en l'occurrence j'en avais pas besoin
refusant la table de négociations et se
prennent dans la figure comme un
boomerang le fait d'avoir envoyé sur le
référendum sur lot pour vous voulez vous
aider même chose sur les cheminots sont
les premiers qui en pâtissent et ceux
qui font la grève
enfin les grès les grévistes sont les
premiers à plaindre finalement les
comptes et personne ne souhaite gergiev
personne ne certaines journées de
salaire mais il ya des causes évidemment
il ya des conséquences d une séquence
dans la vie quotidienne et personne ne
cherche à nuire aux usagers personne ne
cherche à nuire à l'autre en
l'occurrence la grève a passé un moyen
un moment de l'hôpital avec un brassard
mais travailler quand même manifester
son désaccord mais être là présent mais
si cela suffisait si cela permettait
effectivement qu'on ouvre la négociation
et qu'on puisse obtenir un certain
nombre de choses et de réparation des
problèmes qui sont celles et ceux de
l'hôpital par exemple ou des contrôleurs
aériens etc
eh bien je pense que l'immense majorité
le ferais personne n'a envie de donner
une journée de salaire
surtout avec les salaires qui sont les
nôtres aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir souvent obtenir simplement
que leurs droits empêcher qu'on détruise
leur cadre collectif et généralement pas
obtenir de cholet mention d'abord à
dernière question à un petit mot sur
votre prédécesseur jean claude mailly a
été très sympathique le dernier jour du
congrès à lille et qui on l'a appris il
ya quelques jours vient de partir dans
l'entreprise de raymond soubie qui avait
longtemps conseillé nicolas sarkozy
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire sur
l'avenir du dirigeant syndical qu'est ce
qu'on fait après avoir écouté parce que
j'ai beaucoup de réactions en internat
force ouvrière depuis sa désignation au
cabinet de monsieur soubie surtout pour
les missions qui vont être les siennes
qui s'inscrivent quand même dans une
logique d'accompagner aussi des plans de
restructuration ici patronaux et au
niveau des entreprises donc il ya une
vraie colère une vraie grogne interne à
force ouvrière au niveau des militants
et qui me disent également que puisque
jean claude mailly s'était auto-désigné
oc européen avant de partir il ya une
incompatibilité entre un tel choix
professionnel qui lui appartient c'est
un homme libre et le fait de garder un
mandat à force ouvrière donc été il
s'est auto des îles s'est auto-désignée
au mandat au seuil européen mois avant
que je sois secrétaire général c'est
assez incompatibles eu égard à ces
missions aujourd'hui et au fait de cette
eau désignation sur le 16 octobre les
jeux quand il fera un choix non moi je
ne serais rien je ne ferai rien jean
claude mailly fera en l'occurrence qu'il
veut mais en l'occurrence il faut non à
north bay excusez moi mais jean-claude
mali est sorti de l'organisation en
disant je n'aurai ni mandat est faux et
vous n'entendrez plus parler de moi je
constate qu'il s'auto désignent sur un
mandat est faux et excusez moi mais
j'aimerais bien qu'on arrête de parler
de lui très bien et c'est la fin on a
fini merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui
la semaine prochaine c'est eric ciotti
qui sera notre invité de l événement
aura tjrs ainsi lui aussi et pour une
hausse de 20 % du smic bonsoir à très
vite pour se former l'homme
[Musique]
non